how are you Bob I'm good how you doing
mom better for talking to you you know
as soon as I heard about the passing of
Keith Jackson you know I thought of
Saturdays Saturday nights they thought
about how he made Michigan football
bigger and then I'll be honest I thought
of you I thought who can I get on this
show could talk about Keith Jackson I
said let's get Bob Griese so I
appreciate you calling and I give you
the floor who was Keith Jackson to
people who might not know well I think
what you saw on the air on Saturday
afternoons is what Keith Jackson really
was off the air the rest of the week he
was a very humble man very modest man he
grew up in the country in the state of
Georgia
people say whoa Nellie was that was the
warden le come from and I asked he said
myself you know about four or five years
into this I said I said King nothing
well how did you get grown le and Nellie
was my horse grease back in back on the
farm he had a horse by the name of
Nellie and when he started broadcasting
when some big play what happened that
that Nellie just came out with behind
the wool and that's that's how that's
how it got out there but he but he was
up he was a it was an ex-marine a lot of
people don't know that he not a high
school into the Marines he lied about
his age to get in after we got out of
the Marines he what the Washington State
University the Edward all moral school
of broadcasting when he went after there
he went to Seattle you know went into
the sports reporting business in Seattle
and then I got on with ABC and as they
say the rest is history
and then part of that history of you
calling games of them Bob was that day
in the Rose Bowl where your son's
playing for Michigan and then his alma
mater is out there on the field
- what was that broadcast like all year
all year he'd been kind of kind of
laughing and smoking in the background
while I answered all these questions
about you know calling a fair game and
my son's playing and all this other
stuff and now the Rose Bowl game his
alma mater Washington states in the game
and all these questions are directed at
him his teeth are you gotta call a fair
game and all that stuff but the most
memorable moment in my broadcasting
career most memorable moment in my
playing career everybody ask you these
questions was winning the Super Bowl
after the 17 and old season and going
undefeated and the most memorable moment
in my broadcasting career was that goals
ballgame Michigan undefeated the ranked
number one in the country and playing
Washington State who had a great
quarterback by the name of Ryan Leaf
Peyton Manning was at Tennessee that
year Riley was the number two
quarterback and Brian but somewhere down
the line
Brian's the quarterback at Michigan
Michigan wins as a national champion and
so Brian is a pretty good game we got
about 15 seconds left
in the Rose Bowl game Michigan's go to
win and the assistant there with a hand
stick sir arm and hands a 5x7 file card
between my shoulder and Keith's shoulder
and he takes it and I said wow it must
be a promo or lead to a commercial or
something
Keith holds on to it for about 15
seconds and then he says Hardin Ellie
you want to know who the MVP is I'm
standing right next to his proud daddy I
said I did Keith you better take it from
here because I can't talk
well it's a good thing I had such an old
time great - you're right who would
definitely be able to handle that give
it Bob Griese here on the Rich Eisen
show was the first time you met Keith
when you were a player and he was doing
Monday Night Football perhaps I'm just
wondering the first time you ever
crossed paths Keith Jackson well it's a
good question I no I don't think no I
don't think he didn't do that
Monday night gig but for one week one
year I just got it off the ground
no I I think the first time I met him
was this was when I was gonna work with
him I was you know when I retired I went
I did five years with NBC in doing NFL
games and after that gig was up
ABC came and said we want you to come
over the ABC and do college football I
said college football I haven't done
college football in 20 years I played 15
years with the Dolphins and then five
more with NBC doing NFL and I've done
that for 20 years why do you let me do
that well I said well we want you to be
see think you'd be a good fit with our
number one guy Keith Jackson I want you
to come over and do the through the Rose
Bowl game and back then there wasn't any
championship games but if you know
number one number two would have we
would have done it so I said well that
sounds pretty good and so I did I went
over and the first time Keith and I sat
down to do an opening was in the
University of Washington and Keith I
don't forget this he he says all right
lad you're sitting there writing toward
the camera just before the opening how
you wanted to do this
I said le here you're the expert at this
yeah I'm the rookie I just came out of
playing and doing an NBC and pro ball I
don't know anything about golly ball you
lead the way and I'll follow and he said
all right that sounds like a good good
idea
we'll do it so that was my first time
working with Keith and he was just he
was so humble and so he just said what
do you want to do how you want to do
this I said no no no well I'll follow
you take your lead yeah
your father's lead for 13 seasons so
what last couple for you Bob Griese here
on the Rich Eisen show what was it like
having dinner with him it was it was a
hoot that's one of those words that
hasn't been thrown out and in the last
few days I haven't heard that it was a
real hoot
every Thursday night you know with big
games on Saturday would usually get
there on Thursday at dinner on Thursday
night and we neither have by ourselves
so by with some of the crews will be
with us and there'd always be a bottle
of red wine
no released one bottle maybe a couple
and there'd be a little kettle one going
around oh yeah and and Keith Keith was
was always the sweetest guy I mean we
would either be two of us so four of us
or six of us and if anybody came by you
know the other people in the restaurant
would come by and want to talk to Keith
and want to get his autograph he was
just the most accommodating a guy you'd
ever want to meet you know he never
turned anybody down
I I was the I was there in have you seen
1999 I think this was right when he said
yeah I got his acceptance speech when he
received the gold medal from the College
Football Hall of Fame and won the one
little excerpts from this thing I wanna
I'm gonna read you he signed it he
signed this speech a two-page little
speech and gave it to me I put it under
glass and I've got it on my wall here
okay and I want to
give you a part of it please
okay for nearly half a century I have
stood at the edge of your stage for the
simple purpose of definition never
wanting to intrude but rather enhance I
hope I have done that I have certainly
tried that's the way Keats was he was he
was one too he wanted to amplify clarify
and don't enter truth I told Keith one
time I said Keith all this business
about whoa Nellie and Big Uglies I said
we could we could put that rule Nellie
on a golf shirt Big Uglies on a ball cap
and you could you can make some money
found those suckers and people would
love love to have them nope
Griese said I had to go to do it it's
about the kids it's not about me and
that's the way he was never wanted to
intrude only to enhance Bob I cannot
thank you enough for sharing those
stories and and thank you for calling in
and and giving us a piece of Voe what a
great man he was a great guy and he was
he was a loving husband to his wife
Terry Ann and he was a great friend and
little missing Bob thanks again we'll
chat down the line appreciate it okay
that's a Bob Griese the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience